let's revise
there's two kinds of progressions that
were interested in this topic right aps
and gps what does gp stand for again
good now what what makes a gp a gp as
opposed to an ap what's the
characteristic that it has
that's right so every as you go from
term to term you're multiplying by
something over and over and over right
now
after we wrote that all out we came up
with a formula for the sum of a gp right
with a given first term a given ratio
and a given number of terms right can
you rehearse for me what's the formula
a
times
okay
now we also noted there was another way
to write this which was to flip around
the numerator and the denominator
okay now to come think a little bit
short if you want a more detailed
explanation um you can go watch the
video um i want to consider the very
special case where
the ratio that you've got
doesn't make numbers bigger but makes
them progressively smaller okay so if
our ratio is 2 for instance
your numbers are going to increase in
size right but if your number is a half
sorry if your ratio is a half
then your terms are going to decrease
in size and so on right
so i want to consider this case this
second case right
uh as a catch or the kind of restriction
that i want to place is
um the numbers are going to decrease so
long as
the ratio is between -1 and 1
okay if the ratio is outside those
boundaries if the ratio will say -2
or 15 or anything outside that domain
then the numbers aren't going to shrink
towards something okay they're just
going to keep getting bigger and bigger
and bigger
whether it's positive or negative okay
so this is the kind of domain i'm
interested in which alternatively if you
want to be fancy you'll sometimes see
written with absolute value okay
now
i just want to focus on this term up
here
okay i want us to think about this
for a series like these which have no
end right
what would happen what is going to
happen as i consider the sum of the
whole gp
right
as
this is over here
as n approaching infinity i want to try
and not just consider the first 50 or
100 terms what if i could try and
consider all of them okay
what would happen
now
have a look at this guy okay r to the n
okay i'm going to use our language for
calculus to try and say well what's that
going to approach
as an approaching infinity as i climb
off to enormous numbers a million terms
a billion terms and so on
now
it's going to approach zero but the
question is why
why would it approach 0
yeah exactly right
and you can see that happening let me
just repeat that when you multiply a
fraction by itself it gets smaller and
this kind of demonstrates exactly what's
happening right and it's shrinking quite
fast isn't it
so therefore
if this part of this is going to zero
right if i apply that limit to the whole
lot
limit as n approaches infinity of
the whole sum
okay
um this is going to be the limit
as n approaches infinity of this
okay now look at those terms right
as n approaches infinity
what happens to a
nothing it just stays a whatever that
first term was right what happens to one
nothing you see where i'm going right if
there's any term
that doesn't get affected by n which
isn't connected by n right 2n nothing
happens to it which includes these guys
down here this goes down here now you
see why i was focusing on this
we've just established that it
approaches zero right so if i evaluate
my limit out
it's going to be a times one minus zero
on one minus r
which is this
okay
now because
there's an infinite number of terms
right it's sort of tempting to call it
um the sum to infinity okay but that's a
bit shifty n is meant to be a number of
some kind right and we've established
before that infinity is not a number
it's a useful concept but it's not like
you can sub it in and get something
meaningful out of it so they just call
it
capital s
yeah they shouldn't they really
shouldn't for the reason i just said
so this put a big box around it this is
what we mean by
the limiting sum can you see why it's
called limiting by the way
because it has to do with taking the
limit as n approaching infinity right
okay now you you who are here yesterday
i'm almost caught up to you okay but i
want to illustrate this to everyone and
then we'll look at the series that i
challenged you with at the end of the
day okay
this series up here
right
what's it going to equal to it it
behaves
it according to these rules the ratio is
between minus one and one it's a half
which is fine okay so using this
limiting sum formula
what would we get as the answer let's
try it out
the sum is now what's the first term in
this particular series
it's a it's one right
divide by now uh
what's the common ratio
it's just a half right
one minus a half
so that's one divided by a half which is
two
okay